- Good morning, everyone.
I speak for the entire university
when I say that it is a deep honor
and a very sincere pleasure to
welcome Daw Aung San Suu Kyi,
chair of the National League
for Democracy in Burma,
a member of parliament to Yale.
It is just a very special privilege for us
to have you with us.
I believe that everyone in this audience
knows the basic outline of
Daw Suu's extraordinary story.
The daughter of Aung
San who liberated Burma
from colonial rule before being cruelly
assassinated in 1947,
she spent many years outside
Burma being educated at Oxford
and raising a family there.
When her mother became very ill,
she returned to Burma in 1988
only to find that a student
uprising was restoring
some sense of hope to
the millions of Burmese
under oppressive military rule.
She quickly became the leader
of the movement for democracy
assuming the mantle with
humility, bravery and courage.
She famously defied
soldiers whose loaded guns
were aimed directly at her
inspiring the U2 song, Walk On.
She was placed under house
arrest soon thereafter
and spent more than 15 of the
next 20 years in isolation.
Released from house
arrest in November 2010
and elected to parliament
in April of this year,
she has continued her
crusade for the rights
of the Burmese people.
Thanks to Daw Suu's
courage and the inspiration
she is provided to the people of Burma,
the prospects for the
restoration of democracy
are greater now than they
have been for decades.
Since her release from house arrest,
Daw Suu has partnered with
Burma's new civilian government
to help lead a period of rapid political
and economic liberalization.
The government has released
hundreds of political prisoners
and granted substantial
freedom to the press.
The United States and many other nations
have reciprocated these
actions by easing sanctions
and pledging foreign aid.
But because a democratic
future is not fully assured,
Daw Suu's work is not yet done.
Daw Suu was honored with the
Nobel Peace Prize in 1991
and with a Congressional
Gold Medal last week.
Jane and I had the
privilege of hearing her
speak last Friday when she
received the Global Citizen Award
from the Atlantic Council.
As you will see momentarily,
she is a true inspiration.
In a beautiful essay that
Daw Suu wrote in 1990
entitled Freedom from Fear,
she claimed that Nehru words
describing Mahatma Gandhi
could be applied to her father, Aung San.
I would suggest that they
apply equally well to her
and I paraphrase here
to get the gender right.
The essence of her teaching
is fearlessness and truth
and action allied to these
always keeping the welfare
of the masses in view.
As she, herself, has said about the poetry
that she reveres and from
which she takes strength,
Daw Suu is, and I quote, a great unifier
that knows no frontiers of space or time.
Today, I'm pleased to announce that Yale
is taking several small
steps to facilitate
the reforms underway in Burma.
First, we are stepping up our
admissions recruitment efforts
for students from Burma
and we will be communicating more broadly
the fact little known there
that the parents of
applicants to Yale College
who make less than $65,000
a year are not required
to make a contribution
to their child's tuition.
Second, we will work to implement
an idea discussed yesterday with Daw Suu
to bring high school teachers
and principals to Yale
to encourage them to raise
the sights of their students
to advise them, and to
advise them on the generous
financial aid programs available at Yale
and elsewhere in the United States.
And finally, I'm particularly
pleased to announce
that with the cooperation of
the Council On Southeast Asia
Studies at Yale, we will
support the establishment
of a successor publication
to the Journal of the
Burma Research Society,
a prominent vehicle for
scholarly publication on Burma
before it was shut down by the
military regime in the 1970s.
As Dean Brenzel mentioned to you,
the Chubb Fellowship is
among the highest honors
accorded to a visitor at Yale.
Since 1949, Chubb Fellows have included
former presidents of the United States,
numerous heads of state
and prominent figures
from government, industry and the arts.
Today's Chubb Fellow adds
luster to that luminous list.
Please join me in
welcoming Aung San Suu Kyi.
(attendees applauding)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Thank you, thank you
for a very warm welcome.
The subject on which
I'm going to speak today
is rule of law.
Not rule of law as you might
be taught in your classrooms,
that, your professors can
do far more competently
than I could ever hope to
but rule of law as I see it
and others like me in Burma see it
and why rule of law is important to us.
To begin with, I had a very healthy
minimum contact with the law until 1988.
Up to 1988, the only two
contacts, shall we say,
I had had with the law
whereas a student at Oxford.
Once, I was cycling the wrong
way down a one-way street
and ran straight into a police patrol car.
The policeman put out
his head and looked at me
and asked me if I knew
that was a one-way street.
I said, yes, so he proceeded on his way
and I hopped off my bike
and proceeded on mine.
The second time also was at Oxford when,
at an artist before dusk
and the roads were empty.
I cycled absent-mindedly
through a red light
and the roads were empty
but for a patrol car
which is right behind me.
So I should have known
then that my contacts
of the security forces were
going to be unique in future.
The real contact came in 1988 and '89
when I was first placed
under house arrest.
This was on the 20th
July, 1989 and suddenly,
hordes of policemen and uniformed soldiers
came into my compound and
rounded up everybody there.
I was kept in the house.
I thought they were going to
take me away to prison as well
but they left me in the
house in the house arrest
and took the others away to prison.
They had brought a detention
order and they read it up.
This order said that they were,
they were placing me under house arrest
in accordance with the law meant to,
how did they put it?
To protect the state against
destructive elements.
I was a destructive element so this meant
that I could be placed under
house arrest without trial.
Now this is section 10.
Section 10 has two parts
to it, 10A and 10B.
10A means imprisonment without trial.
10B is house arrest without trial.
I was placed at a house arrest and a 10B.
According to that law, the detention order
would have to be renewed every six months
and was renewable for a
total period of three years
and the decision as to whether or not
they would renew the detention order
would be made by what they call
the central committee of ministers.
This is a small group of
three or four ministers
including the home minister.
At that time, I had had
so very little to do
with such matters that I had assumed
that they had placed me under house arrest
because this was in accordance with law.
I was alone in the house.
My two sons were with me for a short while
but then they left to go back to England
but they kept me in the
house and the security forces
took up their residence in my compound.
I thought also then
that this was what they
were entitled to do.
It was only years later I learned
that they were not entitled
to take up residence
within my compound.
So this is the beginning of the time
when I realized how very little
I knew about the laws of the land
and how very little I
knew about whether or not
these laws were respected.
I was allowed a shortwave radio
which get me in touch with outside world
and I learned from this
radio that more and more
of the members of my
party were been arrested
and most often, they were
arrested under section five.
Section five is the law
that was brought out in 1950
to cope with what they called emergency,
emergency situation of that time
because there were many insurgencies then.
Under section five, we used to,
later, we, politicians
sort of refer to it as
I can't bear you law.
Anybody that they didn't like,
they could grab under section
five and put them away
for a period of up to
five years but they would
slap other charges against these people
and could give them up to 20
years which they have done.
I think our longest
that a member of our party who served
the longest single period in jail
stayed there for 18 years and three months
although he was originally
supposed to have been imprisoned
only for about five years.
So my own experiences made me understand
that there was no rule of law in Burma.
The law was used by those in
authority for their own ends.
The law was not there to protect
the people of the country.
Section five, section 10 and
then there were other sections
which I became very familiar with.
Section 17 which was
to do with association
in the unlawful organizations.
These were the sections
used by the military regime
to put the members of the NLD in prison
at any time they felt like it
and to keep them for
as long as they wished.
Section 10 was amended when the time came
near for my release three years
after I had first been
placed under house arrest.
They changed it so that
they could keep me in
for more than that and in fact,
they kept me in for six years.
Have you ever heard of a law been changed
simply to keep one
person longer in prison?
This shows you what it meant
not to be under the rule of law.
While I was under house arrest
and listening to the news of the arrest
of so many of my colleagues,
I decided that we needed
a legal aid committee.
We didn't have any such
thing in our country.
I don't think it had ever been known.
So the moment I was released
after my first term of
house arrest in 1995,
I explained to our party
that we must have a legal aid committee.
The person I chose to head this committee
was then the chairman of our NLD, U Tin Oo
who used to be the commander-in-chief
of the Burmese army and
he was a trained lawyer.
He took up door after he
was expelled from the army.
I asked him to form
this legal aid committee
to protect those of our
colleagues who were charged
under some section or the other
but all these sections were just an excuse
for putting them away,
for keeping them out of active politics.
And when I put the suggestion
to U Tin Oo, he was not,
he was a very,
well, he still is
a really good professional soldier.
He obeys orders in a very
straightforward manner
and he always looked upon me
as what he used to call his commander.
So when I said please, would you head
the legal aid committee?
He said, yes, but months later he told me
that he didn't believe in it.
He said yes and he took on this job
because I had asked him to.
He did not believe that
it would do any good
because he said we would
never have won any case
when we were trying to
defend our colleagues
who had been charged with,
charged under section five
or 10 or any of those other
very questionable sections.
But I explained to him that I knew
we would probably not be
able to win the freedom
of our colleagues once
they had been arrested
but first of all, I wanted our people
to be confident that they
would not be abandoned,
that they would be
defended as far as possible
in accordance with the laws of the land.
And secondly, I said that all these cases
would remain on record
and that was necessary for the future.
These cases of lack of rule of law
would be there forever on
record for future generations
to see what they should avoid.
He accepted my explanation
but he showed no indication whatsoever
that he didn't really think it was,
it would have any positive results
but later, he admitted that he was wrong.
The heart that we put into our colleagues,
they all knew that they would
probably not get away with it,
that we would not be able
to obtain the release
but they were happy
that somebody was there
to stand up in court to defend them
which had not been the case
before we found the legal aid committee.
A few of our brave
lawyers had come forward
to defend prisoners of conscience
to those charged under
those various sections
but we had never won a case
and we didn't win any cases.
Of the thousands of
cases that were taken up
by our legal aid
committee, we won only one,
one single case and the judge was a woman.
I don't know whether
thus is any significance
but I must also add that after
she had passed judgment
freeing our prisoner.
she was sent off to a remote
provincial town as a punishment
for daring to do justice by us.
So we learned as we went along
that without rule of law,
our people were never
going to be free from fear.
They would always be afraid
that even if they had done nothing wrong,
action could be taken against them
in accordance with the
so-called laws of the land.
So the importance of rule
of law was made known to us
through our daily experience.
Many of our people in
those days were arrested
for such small matters as the distribution
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
This was considered very dangerous.
The NLD was trying to let our people know
what their rights were
because Burma was a signatory
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
and in fact, at that
time, the military regime
had come to an agreement
with the United Nations
to disseminate the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
as widely as possible.
So what we were doing was in accordance
with what the military
government had undertaken to do
and yet, some of our
people were arrested simply
for distributing copies
of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
So for us human rights and
rule of law went together.
It says in the preamble to the
United Nations' declaration
that human rights should be
protected by the rule of law
and we believe that this
is absolutely essential.
Unless there's rule of law,
there can be no guarantee of human rights.
So,
when the NLD decided to contest
the by-elections last April,
we put forward as the main plank
of our election platform, rule of law.
There are three main planks.
Rule of law, an end to ethnic conflict
and amendments to the constitution.
Some have questioned whether it was right
to put rule of law before
end to ethnic conflict.
We did that because we think
that practically speaking,
we cannot bring an end
to the ethnic conflict
unless there's rule of
law, unless we can assure
our ethnic nationalities that
justice will not only be done
but seen to be done for them.
They would not be able to
support any peace process
with full confidence.
So we think rule of law is the first step
towards a genuine
democratic society in Burma.
And because of what we have suffered,
we knew from experience that rule of law
is what rules our lives from day to day
and if it is rule of unjust laws,
then we are ruled
unjustly from day to day.
These sections that I
have mentioned earlier,
sections 10 and five should
never have been practiced.
We want these to be removed completely
from the body of our law
but this has not yet been possible.
We are trying to,
we are trying very hard
within the legislature
but I have to remind everybody
that we are very small minority
as yet to remove these laws
which are misused by the authorities
to deprive the people of the basic rights.
You can charge anybody
with those sections.
When you say that somebody
is a destructive element,
what exactly does it mean?
How do you prove whether or
not I'm a destructive element?
But the authorities decided
that I was a destructive element.
I was a danger to the peace
and tranquility of the state
and therefore, I could be
put away for years and years.
The first time was six years
and then about two years
and then the last time again, six years.
So,
I was, of course, much
better off under house arrest
and my colleagues in prison but
the section under which
they were placed in prison,
section five is equally destructive
of basic human rights
because there is,
section five has a very peculiar
part to it that if you act
in such a way as to diminish
the love of the people for the government,
then you can be charged
under section five.
Now, how do you decide whether or not
you have done anything to diminish
somebody's love from something else?
It's so vague and it's so broad,
you can just pull anybody in.
This is why we decided that
we would run for by-elections
on this platform putting
rule of law at the very head.
And after we contested
by-elections and we did well,
we won 43 out of the 44
seats that we contested,
we entered the parliament
at the National Assembly
and since I've been in
the National Assembly,
the speaker has made me chairman
of the Committee for Rule
of Law and Tranquility.
I know you will laugh.
Everybody smiles when I say
rule of law and tranquility
but it's a nice thought.
(attendees laughing)
As a practical step
towards re-establishing
rule of law in the country,
we organized a seminar with retired judges
and experienced lawyers to
find out what we could do
to restore rule of law in Burma.
I say restore because once upon a time,
we did have rule of law in Burma
and some of the old lawyers
spoke the old judges book
and one of them taught about
the independence of the judiciary
which we had enjoyed after we
became an independent nation.
We were a parliamentary democracy
and the judiciary exercised
considerable independence.
I think if you want to read
about the early history
of the judiciary in Burma,
you'll have to read Dr. Maung Maung
who was at Yale's Law School
as a Ford Foundation scholar
for a couple of years before
the first military coup.
He later became, for briefly,
the president of Burma
after the uprising 1988
but he did not stayed
in his post very long.
In this study,
you will find that we did
have considerable independence
of the judiciary but with
the military takeover,
this independence was also destroyed.
Our old judges and lawyers wanted us
to re-establish the
independence of the judiciary
and that, of course, is
of primary importance
because under the military regime,
the judiciary was totally under
orders from the executive.
At the trial of political activists,
the judges quite openly would
wait for a small envelope
to be put in front of them.
They would open it and in that envelope
would be the sentence that
they were expected to pass
on the prisoner's chart and
they would pass sentence.
We try to teach the members of our party
to ask those who came to arrest
them, what the charges were
and whether they or
not they had a warrant.
And one of our members just that
when a troop of security
officers came to arrest him.
He said, "Do you have a warrant
and what are the charges?"
And the man said, "Don't be ridiculous.
"We've already decided what
the sentence is going to be."
So this is rule of law in Burma.
And he thought it was perfectly
all right for him to do this
and he was simply trying
to let our man know
that he should not engage
in such stupid activities
as trying to get the law to work for him.
The law only worked for those in power.
That was lack of rule of law meant for us.
The law only worked for
those who are in power,
for those who are in authority.
It is not there to protect the people
or to protect our democratic rights.
But, of course, the military
regime did not believe
in democratic rights.
But now, as the chairman of
the committee for rule of law,
we have to work in a practical way
to re-establish an independent judiciary
which has the confidence of the people.
Our people no longer
believe in the judiciary.
Democracy requires a balance
between the three branches
of the executive, the
legislature and the judiciary.
We have hardly a judicial
branch to speak of
because it had been so
crushed under the executive
for so many years.
Some of our advisors in that seminar
suggested the best way in
which we could re-establish
an independent and respectable judiciary
would be to educate people
who would be judges.
They said, one of the old lawyer said,
the reason why we did not
have rule of law in Burma now
was because we no longer had judges
who were well-trained in the law
and well-trained in the
practices of justice.
This is why, he said,
there is so much corruption
in the courts of Burma
and simply by producing educated judges,
we would be able to remedy the situation.
I think this is too simplistic.
It is not that easy to
change the ways of people
who have become corrupt over the years.
Judges who have become
corrupt cannot be changed
simply by sending them to
special courses at Yale.
They may in fact learn--
(attendees laughing)
So, it's not just a question
of acquiring a good education.
It's a question of attitudes,
of mindset.
Over the years, not just as judges
but as civil servants in general
have become very corrupt.
They became corrupt to begin with
because their salaries were
inadequate and in order to
make sure that they would be
able to leave decent lives
and educate their children,
they started asking for
bribes and getting them.
Now, people who get
used to that way of life
cannot go back to the
old clean ways easily.
A civil servant with a
decent salary in Burma
in the old days could
live a respectful life.
He would have a house,
he would have a car.
His children would be
able to go to good schools
and he would be respected by
the community in which he lived
and that was enough
for civil servants then
but during the years of corruption,
civil servants, some civil
servants became very wealthy.
They would have several
houses, several cars,
their children would enjoy
all kinds of privileges
and to expect those people
to go back to the old
ways would be difficult.
Even if we were to give
them adequate salaries now,
the kind of salaries that
would allow them to live
like well respected civil servants
but not like millionaires,
they would not be satisfied with it
because they've got used
to a different way of life.
So it's not just re-education
in the technical sense.
It's re-education with regard
to attitudes and mindset,
how do we persuade these people
who have got used to a
very opulent way of life
that they can make do with a
more modest standard of living
but need clean lives
that will gain them
the respect of society.
It's very difficult so their
rule of law comes in again.
Action will have to be taken.
It's not enough simply to say
we're now paying you a decent salary.
You live within its means.
They will have to be laws
that will enable else
to take action against civil servants
and against judges who are corrupt.
So rule of law will engender rule of law.
We have to start by imposing rule of law
on the judiciary itself.
That is not going to be an easy task.
We need help with this judicial reforms.
Our committee has started by investigating
three courts of justice just to find out
what the actual practices
are, what do the judges do,
how does the government attorney behave
and what kind of justice
do those who come for justice expect?
These practical measures we are taking
that we may make practical recommendations
to the various departments concerned.
The home ministry, the defense ministry,
the attorney general's office,
the information ministry.
All of these will have to
be involved in our efforts
to re-establish rule of law in Burma.
If we manage to do this,
this would be a tremendous
breakthrough for our country.
Once we can say that we have been able
to re-establish rule
of law, then we can say
that the process of
democratization has succeeded.
Until that point, I do
not think we can say
that the process of
democratization has succeeded.
It is not enough just to simply make laws
which we are doing in the legislature.
We have to make sure
that these laws are just
and not only just but that these laws
are implemented in the right way.
There must be due process
as well as just laws.
So until we can do that, we
cannot say that democracy
is on a safe road.
People ask me, have we reached the point
when democracy has become,
the democratization has
become irreversible?
And I say no.
No, because to begin with, the
constitution is in the way.
The constitution allows the
military extraordinary powers.
And as long as the military
possesses these powers,
we cannot say that we are on
the true road to democracy
which is why we have linked these three.
Rule of law, end to ethnic conflict
and amendments to the constitutions.
These are all linked.
If democracy is to be
restored to our country,
we must have all three.
Without one, the other two will fail too.
We can't have rule of law
and not have amendments
of the constitution
and an end to ethnic conflict.
We cannot achieve the other
two without rule of law.
So because of these links, we
put the greatest importance
on the re-establishment of rule of law.
It will mean on a practical basis
that our people can be safer, more secure
within the laws of the land.
I am sure I do not have
to explain to law students
that rule of law is not
the same as rule by law
and that laws alone are not enough.
They have to be just laws.
So,
Burma is now
at the beginning of a path
and I keep repeating
that this is going to be
the most difficult road we have to travel.
Too many people think that
there has been a breakthrough.
I don't think we can say
We have been given the opportunity
to achieve a breakthrough.
This morning, there is a word,
achieve, used a few times
and I made the point that
we have yet to achieve.
We have not yet achieved
but we have been given the
opportunity to achieve.
And in this process, we need
help from different directions
and I would like to take this opportunity
to ask for your help and support
with regard to the establishment
of rule of law in Burma.
We need well-trained lawyers.
We need well-trained judges.
We need a good law school at our,
good law schools in our universities.
We need contact between the
members of our judiciary
and the members of the judiciaries
of practicing democracies.
There is so much that we need.
We need broad education
with regard to write
as well as responsibilities.
People are very keen on democratic rights
but they do not always want to
know about responsibilities.
But if we want rule of law in Burma,
we must put equal emphasis on both
rights as well as responsibilities.
Citizens who expect the
protection of the law
must themselves respect the law.
If we are to achieve all these,
then I think we can be confident
that Burma will be firmly
on the road to democracy.
For years, we have suffered
from lack of rule of law
which means that we can never be sure
what is going to happen to us next.
This is a fact in Burma.
For many years, we would
have to ask every day
who was arrested the night before
because arrest were usually
made in the middle of the night
and we had to find out in the morning
which of our colleagues were still free
and which of them had been put
into prison during the night
or taken away to the police station
and often, we would never know
where they had been taken.
1998, we formed the Committee Representing
the People's Parliament.
That is to say this
committee was supposed to be
a committee representing
those who had been elected
in the 1990 elections which
were ignored by the military
because we won too well.
And because we declared
that we would be forming this committee,
many, many of our elected representatives
were taken away into custody.
They were told that the authorities
wanted to discuss the convening
of parliament with them
but in fact, they were simply taken away
to military cantonments,
to police stations
and kept there for weeks
without contact with their families.
They were not charged under
any section of the law.
They were just kept there
week after week after week.
Then they were allowed to come back home.
I don't quite know why they
allowed them to come back home.
Every couple of weeks, they
would be allowed to go back home
and then they would be taken
back again into custody
and this went on for more than a year
and this was how it was in Burma.
If you have anything to do with politics,
your life is never secured.
They can take action against
you in any way they pleased.
My own experience at Depayin.
Depayin was 2003 when I was
campaigning in Northern Burma
and as the campaign proceeded,
the support of the public
became stronger and stronger
and one evening while I was traveling
from one place to another,
our car was stopped.
It was stopped by a monk who said
that he wanted me to give a speech.
Dusk was coming on and we had been warned
that there might be problems
so we said no, it was too late
and there were no
arrangements for me to speak
at that particular place
so we would have to go on
but he kept on trying to
persuade us to stop for a bit
and then somebody came
running up from the back
of our motorcade and said that
troops of thugs had arrived
and they were beating up
our people at the back.
This was what the Depayin
incident was about.
Some of those thugs were dressed as monks
but they were obviously not monks
because they all have white
handkerchiefs tied to one arm.
I think this was to
indicate that they belonged
to the same group and
they had enormous staffs.
They killed four of our people.
They just beat them to
death and they also beaten
the windows of my car.
But I had very good driver.
I did not go on because I felt
that I had to wait for the others
and I couldn't just leave
them to be beaten up
then the young man who
was driving my car said,
"Look, they're putting
barriers up across the road
"in front of us," and
I saw that and he said,
"I think they're trying to cut us off
"from our people who are coming
from the other direction.
"Shall I drive through the barrier?"
So I said, yes, drive through
the barrier so we can meet up.
Well, what did you what
did you expect me to do?
(attendees laughing)
It was very exciting.
I had never been in a car that
leaped over a barrier before.
But when he got to the other side
we found that there was nobody there.
They was just trying to cut us off
from all the roads around us
and I don't know what the intentioned was,
whether it was just to beat all of us up
or to arrest all of us but
when we got over the barrier,
we found nothing and we kept
going and going and going
until we go to the next
time when we were arrested.
Now, the point is that we were
the ones who were beaten up
but we were put in prison
as destructive elements.
So this is a great mystery to us.
What had we done to
deserve this imprisonment?
We hadn't raised a finger.
Yet, that was the reason why I
was placed under house arrest
for the next six years which
stretched to seven years
because there was the
episode of the American
who came swimming to my house
bringing greetings from
all of you, no doubt.
So, I was kept under house
arrest for seven years.
The last year and a half that
I was kept under house arrest
on the grounds that I had not turn
the visitor over to the police,
I had not turned him over to the police
because I did not believe
that he would receive justice from them.
We had never received
justice from the authorities
and I thought that it
would be immoral of me
to turn over somebody
to the security forces
when I knew that he would
not be given justice.
Mind you, I shouldn't have
worried so much about him
because since he was not Burmese,
he was let go pretty soon
but I was, of course, kept
on for another 18 months
beyond the time when I
should have been released.
This, I think, was basically
to keep me under house arrest
while the elections of
2010 were conducted.
So the law can be used in any way
that the authorities please
to promote their own political agenda
and that is certainly not rule of law.
Because of that, we are working
very hard in the legislature
to re-establish rule
of law and to make sure
that it goes hand in hand
with other democratic reforms.
If there are no substantial
reforms to the judiciary,
we cannot believe that
this is a true process
of democratization and
I hope this is something
that you will keep in mind,
that you will watch what
is going on in Burma
and be aware of the fact that we have,
that our judiciary at the longest moment
is practically non-existent
and until we have a strong,
independent, clean judiciary,
we cannot say that Burma is
truly on the road to democracy.
I'm saying this because
people have asked me
when they can assume that
Burma has reached the point
and the process is irreversible
and I always say there is no such thing
as an irreversible process
because we were practicing democracy
when the army took over in 1962
so there is never a point where we can say
this is irreversible but
they must come a point
when everybody recognizes it
that to reverse the process
will be far more painful
than to continue along that.
Thank you.
(attendees applauding)
- Can I put your microphone?
- Did I keep it within 40 minutes?
- Thank you so much for those remarks
and for those reflections
on trying to build
a rule of law in Burma.
Now, we've asked people
to submit cards tonight.
I got dozens of wonderful questions
and many are very much
pertinent to the subject
that you were talking about.
So with I hope excuse me if
I don't read your question.
There were many duplicated questions
and I'll do the best I
can to try to synthesize
the spirit of what came
forward to in the floor.
But I thought one of the
interesting questions
about the rule of law, particularly,
it seems appropriate given
the difficulty of making this transition
from a corrupt, essentially lawless,
well, paper laws but laws
that are either oppressive
or not enforced.
How to make that transition
to the kind of regime you envision?
Then question is that many
countries around the world
in the last couple of
decades have experienced
transitions from having
oppressive non-democratic
regimes to greater democracy.
Do you see any examples in
Eastern Europe or Latin America
or any other parts of the world
that have gone through a
transition that seem relevant
or useful to you and thinking about
how to affect the transition in Burma?
- Well, I know some examples which tell us
what we must not do.
I was speaking to some
politicians from Cambodia recently
and they remarked that the fact
that we put so much emphasis
on the rule of law was a good thing.
They said they had neglected
to do that in Cambodia.
They had emphasized the
need for free elections
and a free legislature
but omitted the importance
of rule of law and they had
said that because of that,
Cambodia is now having problems
with taking forward the
process of democratization.
So this is an,
if you like a negative lesson,
we've learned what can happen
without the rule of law.
But I think in other
transitions such as in Indonesia
and in South Africa, they
have tried to strengthen
rule of law as the democratization
process went forward.
I think in South Africa,
perhaps, they had an easier job
than we are going have in Burma
because although there was apartheid
which was ruled by law
rather than rule of law,
at least, there were there
were working judiciaries
which I don't think we
can say off in Burma
so we'd have to start from scratch.
We are in a far weaker position
than many of the countries which have made
the transition to democracy
when it comes to the judiciary.
- One interesting question
asks about the judiciary
and interestingly raises
a number of the things,
questions you did attempt to address like,
the question is what
are the major problems
and how would you, sort
of in a sense, rank them?
Corruption of judiciary,
the lack of courage
and enforcing laws against states.
The competence of judges,
the respect for the
judiciary by the people
and the political will for reform
and it did seem to me you touched almost--
- All that--
- But, in a way, even more.
- Plus, of course, the home department.
That is to say the police.
We need a clean police.
We need the people who
enforce these laws to be,
to able to live within those laws.
This is why we are cooperating
with the home ministry
as well as a defense ministry
in trying to re-establish
rule of law in Burma.
We cannot just deal with the
attorney general's office,
I can't just deal with the courts.
We have to make sure that
a police too are clean
and capable of carrying out
the process of rule of law.
- Seems to me it takes
a kind of political will
on the part, not only populist,
but of these people whose lives
were abused to a corrupt regime
in that transformative ways.
- Yes, it's very difficult to make people
uncorrupt as it were.
As I said, they get used
to certain way of living,
a certain standard of living
and it would be difficult to convince them
that they should take less.
But on the other hand, of course,
we can always recruit new members as well.
- There's several questions here.
You talked about how the
question of the rights
of ethnic minorities interweaves
with the question of
human rights in Burma.
You wanna comment a
little more depth on that?
I mean what is the status of
ethnic minorities in Burma now
and what in the transition
to our democracy,
how do you see those interests
being properly represented?
- The great majority of
the ethnic nationalities
live in the border areas and
as always happens, they can,
more injustices are committed
the further away you move
from the center of government.
This happens everywhere.
And our people, they are poorer,
they have less access to justice,
they have less access to organizations
that might be able to help them.
So unless we can make our
ethnic nationalities feel
that they are on an even footing
with the majority of Burmese,
we will never be able to
achieve genuine harmony
in the country.
One of the request that
I always make to people
who want to invest in Burma
whether in development
or in humanitarian efforts
or in economic enterprises,
I ask them to try to
work as far as possible
in the ethnic nationality areas,
not just to concentrate in that area
in central part of Burma
where the Burmese live
but in the outlying areas to
bring up the standard of living
of our ethnic nationality states
to that of the central area of Burma,
and this would help if there were more,
if our ethnic nationality
areas had more access
to the wider world.
There would be fewer
injustice is committed.
At least they could not
commit this injustices
and get away with them to that extent.
- The connection of ethnic minorities
and religious identity,
there are many religions
practiced in Burma
although the majority are Buddhist
and you obviously, yourself,
have written about the
importance of Buddhist teachings
and practice in your own
thinking, in your own life.
Are there, how would you,
what role is there for
better understanding
across the religious boundaries?
Is that a means to reducing
the inter-ethnic conflicts?
- Some of our nationalities
practice religions
other than Buddhism.
For example, in the Kachin State,
the Baptist church well as
the Roman Catholic church
are very strong, particularly
the Baptist church.
And in the Chin State as well,
Christianity is the dominant religion.
And I have to say, with great sadness,
that there have been
violations against their right
to worship freely particularly
in the Chin State.
Chin fans have complained that
pressure has been put on them
to not to give up their religion
but to practice their
religion less ostentatiously.
The Chins, used to, I thought
it was a beautiful custom.
They used to put up
crucifixes on hilltops.
I think this is beautiful
because this is their religion,
they worship it and it's lovely
to see them from a distance
but at one time, there was a campaign
to get rid of all these crucifixes.
A campaign conducted by Buddhist
and I'm very sorry that this happened.
I do not think that this kind of action
should be allowed at all
and in the Kachin State,
we have found the Christian
churches do very good work
with regard to the
internally displaced people
who have been herded into camps
because of the conflict that
took place over the last year.
We can get help to them best
through the Christian churches.
So a lot of cooperative effort is possible
and this will not only bring
about better understanding
between the different religious
groups and ethnic groups.
I think it is also bring
more practical help
to our ethnic nationalities.
- Buddhist monks played a
significant role in 2007
in the Saffron Revolution.
Is there any prospect of that
using clergy and clergymen
to help cross those lines.
I'd give an example.
Tony Blair taught a course
here for three years
on faith and globalization
in which the real focus
was actually drew from his
experience in Northern Ireland
where he is getting a peaceful
solution in Northern Ireland
was in large part, because of his ability
to work with both Protestant
and Catholic clergy
to help bridge some of the divide.
I wonder is that a strategy
that could help with
the recent ethnic tension?
- I think so.
I think there are a
number of Buddhist monks
and Christian clergymen
who are working towards
such as resolution of conflicts
between their communities.
- And what about the role of
Muslim populations in Burma?
- The Muslim populations
are scattered all over Burma
but, of course, these days
people hear most about
the Muslim population
in the Rakhine State because
of the recent troubles
and there, the communal
problems go back a long way
and I have to say quite frankly
that these are not going
to be resolved overnight.
This is another reason why
I emphasize rule of law
because rule of law can
help to ease tensions.
They will not make the
communal problems go away.
The communal differences cannot
be made to vanish overnight.
It takes a long time, it takes
understanding on both sides,
it takes positive action from both sides.
I'm not saying it's impossible.
I believe it is possible
because there are Muslims
in the Rakhine State who have
lived there for generations
and at peace with their Buddhist neighbors
so I do not see why this kind of peaceful
harmonious relationship
should not be re-established
especially now as the government is saying
that they will respect
the citizenship laws.
I think we should also go a step forward
and review the citizenship
laws to make sure
that they're in keeping with
international standards.
Coming back to sort of the
constitutional framework
which you talked about a bit,
another question asks
given that the current
constitution provides for
sort of reserved percentages
of representation in
parliament for the military,
do you see that as a hindrance
to evolution toward rule
of law or democracy?
- Well, of course, in a genuine democracy,
you can't have an unelected
portion of the legislature
which votes on an equal footing
with those who are elected
but I have to say that
I really, at the moment,
don't mind having them,
the military contingent there
because that's our best
opportunity to get to know them.
(attendees laughing)
It's the truth.
And I think once they get to know us,
they will understand that
we are not against them.
We want to work together with them
to built up the kind of society
that would be good for them
as well as for us.
I've never had so much dealings
with military men in my life
until I enter the legislature.
- A couple of questions
that really go to the issue
of universality versus local variations.
So one question is about
democratic institutions.
I mean, do you see democratic principles
as entirely universal
or is there room or
would it be appropriate
to have significant local variation
and similar question with
respect to human rights.
Are human rights strictly universal
or do values and beliefs
in different societies
were somewhat different
framework for human rights?
- I believe in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
and I believe human rights
should be universal.
But with regard to democracy,
I think there will be local variations.
There will be regional,
national variations.
That cannot be avoided
but that does not mean
I accept their kind of
definition of democracy
which the military regime adopted.
I think they called it
disciplined democracy.
I think that simply means--
(attendees laughing)
- That means disciplined democracy.
- Yes.
And in fact,
I'm rather concern that
some people still think
of the transition towards democracy
as a transition to its
disciplined democracy.
That is to say democracy as
acceptable to the military.
- So one area in the realm of human rights
in which there is actually
quite a bit of variation
across democracies is free speech
we're in this country, for example,
speech is protected even
if it is blasphemous
or criticizes another person's religion
but in many societies,
that kind of speech,
even though there's general
freedom of expression,
that kind of speech is not tolerated.
How do you see that in Burma?
- Under the Burmese constitution,
you are not supposed to attack
other's religious beliefs
and I have to say that
I think attacking
other's religious beliefs
is not
a necessary element
in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights.
You should be free to
practice your own religion
but surely, you should respect
other people's religions as well.
If those religions do not
impinge on your own freedom,
I would never insult another's religion.
I would never say anything disrespectful
of religions that not my own
because I think that in many ways,
that's an abuse of my
right to freedom of speech.
You should not use your
own freedoms to hurt others
or to restrict others
freedoms or to offend others.
If you do not like what
somebody else is doing
because it, in some way,
infringes on your own way of life,
then you can talk it over.
Why can't we have reasonable dialogue
with regard to our differences?
Why do we need to insult others
because they do not believe in
the way in which we believe?
- One more aspect of rule of law has to do
with what can the external world do
to help the advance of ruling in Burma
and there are actually
three different questions
but all pretty much the same,
well, pointing the same direction.
What can the international community to do
to promote the development
of democracy and rule of law?
What can the United Nations do
and what can US foreign policy do?
So people thinking along similar lines.
Do you wanna comment on
where can the outside world
be of help?
- Well, the international community
needs to be aware of the
fact that we need rule of law
if we are really to
progress to its democracy.
I don't want them to ignore
the needs of our judiciary.
I think there's too much concentration now
on the economic side of
changes in my country
and on the political side
but it seems mainly on the economic side.
And we have to be a
little careful of that.
As I said this morning,
a development is no
substitute for democracy.
And economic development
is certainly no substitute
for a weak judiciary.
So awareness is the first way
in which the international
community can help us.
With regard to the United
Nations and the United States,
they could help us in practical ways
with the training of lawyers,
with the training of judges.
I want to set up internships
to help our committee
for the Rule of Law and Tranquility.
So with the establishment
of such internships,
there are many practical
ways in which they can help,
one, our committee and
through the committee,
the re-establishment of
rule of law in our country.
- Well, one of the things the
president of Yale can't do
is commit the Yale Law School
to any particular course of action
but I will have a
conversation with our dean
to see if there's anything we can do
to be helpful on those lines.
One last political question
then I'll turn to a couple of
personal questions to close.
So why did they let you out?
And why is this transition
toward democracy taking place?
What was in the minds of the leaders
that allowed this to happen?
- Well, we've been
discussing this quite a lot
and we tend to forget
the 2008 Constitution.
I think the 2008 Constitution
was aimed a change.
The constitution assures the military
an influential position in
the governance of this country
and since that constitution
was adopted in 2008,
I think the military regime felt
that it was time to go forward
and to institute the kind of changes
which would bring positive
benefits to the country.
There was no doubt about
it that our country
had got poorer and poorer
under successive military governments
and that our people were getting
more and more discontented.
So this is all part of a program
which I believe was
decided on sometime back
and 2010, when the elections
were held to turn the military
government into a civilian one.
That is to say the military
members of the government
retired from the military
and contested the elections of civilians
and became the members of
this new civilian government.
I think most of you know that the majority
of the members of our government
now are ex-military people,
the same people who were
in government before 2010.
But among them are those who wish to
bring about genuine
reform because they know
that the country cannot go on in this way
from economic crisis to economic crisis,
from social crisis to social crisis.
And also, I think reform tends
to take on its own momentum
and this is what we have
to take advantage of.
For whatever reason, reforms
may have been started.
We have to make sure
that they are continued
in the right way and that we all help
to keep it on the right path.
- So no fewer than eight
or 10 students, I think,
asked a version of the following question
that's more personal.
What kept you going through
those years of house arrest
and what kept you focused?
One form of the question was what advice
would you give yourself now if
you could turn the clock back
to 1988 about how to endure that hardship
or another version of the question
is what advice would you give to others
who are facing a similar burden?
- Well, what advice I would give myself
if I could turn the clock back
is that I would have listened much more,
I would have been a better pupil
of my music teacher because--
(attendees laughing)
Really, I really regretted
the hours I wasted
when I should have been
practicing my scales
and exercises because I thought
if I had really studied
music very, very well,
it would have been a great solace to me
throughout the years of house arrest.
There were other things I could do.
I enjoy reading, I had books,
I listened to the radio
but I would very much like
to have been able to play
the piano really well
throughout this year.
Inner resources, that
is what is important.
What you need our inner
resources to keep you going
under all circumstances
and these inner resources
you acquire throughout your,
throughout your life.
Not just during the
years you are at school
but throughout your life and
I would say to young people,
try to strengthen yourself internally.
Don't depend too much on external factors.
You must be able to live with yourself.
I never found it difficult to be alone.
There were so many things I could do well.
If there was nothing else,
I could always think.
You have to learn to do that.
And also, we have a saying in Burmese,
what is important for you
is not just to be able to,
what is the word?
To suffer the hardships of bad fortune
but you also have to know how to suffer
the hardships of good fortune.
Do you understand what that means?
That means that you must not be shaken
by external circumstances.
You must not be tempted away from the path
that you set yourself by the hope of gain,
by the hope of comfort,
that you should not let
yourself be corrupted.
To be corrupted is to
give in to the hardships
of good fortune and you cannot resist
the temptations of good fortune.
To be unable to stand up to hardship
is, of course, not to be able to resist
the hardships of bad fortune.
So you have to be able to do both.
You have to be able to detach yourself
from the immediate circumstances
and think of the greater picture.
You must have an idea of the
sort of person you want to be.
Unless you have such an idea,
you will not be able to hold
true to any one path in life.
Every one of us, especially the young,
must have an idea of the kind of person
he or she would like to be.
I was fortunate in that very early on,
I knew what kind of person I wanted to be.
This is linked to my parents.
I knew what kind of person they
would have wished me to be.
Now, of course, in this day and age,
people will think it's very old-fashioned
to want to comply with the
wishes of one's parents
but sometimes, it's worth a try.
(attendees laughing)
- You know, I had another question
which I think you just answered
which is what advice would you give
to our students here today as
they face their opportunities
to lead and change the world
and I think you've just done that
and so I'm gonna say thank
you so much for inspiring us,
for being here with us.
(attendees applauding)